you want to get nuts let's get nuts
[Music]
Westworld season 2 episode 5 akane know
my and I apologize for pronunciation I
probably butchered that but I don't care
because oh this is good I'm really
really really starting to love this
season it's got a shot at being better
than the season one it has to not watch
the landing but it's on track right now
first of all maybe haha
Mavis bagging Mavis awesome and Tandy
Newton is just gosh she owns this part
there's something about the the look on
her face and the expression of
thoughtfulness and intensity that she
has or you know when she's feeling
sensitive compassion like there's a
whole range of stuff that she goes
through and it's all reads in her face
and it's awesome and I will I'm loving
Shogun world I'm the thing was when we
first realized that they were gonna be
exploring this I remember getting very
nervous because I remember thinking God
how redundant is this gonna be is this
gonna feel totally detached from
everything else that is going on is it's
gonna feel like a tack on you know is
this gonna work
well yeah it's gonna work and it's gonna
work because even though it is a
completely new setting it is still very
much in line with everything we know
about West world and I love the fact
that Maeve and and her little group of
murder friends effectively encounter
their own equivalents there and I love
that it gets explained by this writer
basically kind of shrugged it off like
you try and come up with 300 story lines
in a few weeks and you know it's the
guy's a hack and he was not above
recycling stuff when he knew that the
characters weren't kind of crossover
with each other so of course virtually
the same storyline is going on in Jogja
the world and these are effectively the
same template characters just slapped on
this
while it's not the same razor Ronin but
slapped on to a ronin and a Geisha as
opposed to an outlaw and a madam I love
that I love that that makes total sense
to me and seeing them interact and
seeing the ways that things are ringing
the same bells we get are also slightly
different and I'm lovely cast the the
guys playing the Ronin I can't remember
the the character's name right now but
I've seen him in another stuff I
remember first seeing him in that any
Boyle film sunshine he's good he's I've
seen him in a number of things that most
of the things I've seen him in aren't
great he was in that sci-fi show helix I
think it was called I'm the watch the
first season it was not very good but he
is always good he is a he's one of those
guys was just a great presence and he is
bringing that to the table the the the
geisha Akane
she is she's so good that moment of just
her stabbing the guy me I was like oh
and actually you know what the writers
really started to grow on me especially
with his reactions just seeing somebody
not going that's not supposed to happen
and I feel like I feel like in a lot of
ways he would be me okay I'm just trying
to survive but I think I know what's
going on crap no I don't so I'm digging
that we've still got we still got the
techy still yet Sylvester and Felix in
there I really feel bad for them they
just pull up the cart at this point that
like there's a part of me that wants to
say narrative Lea there's no point in
having them around maybe they should
just keep Hilde off except I can't have
a song swapping guys so I don't want
that to happen
Teddy what I called is kind of going on
earlier I called that Teddy was gonna
directly confront Dolores about
everything that was going down that
hasn't happened so I wasn't right about
that specific but I was right that there
that they were gonna come to a head
and in this case Dolores making the
decision that who Teddy is fundamentally
ie
a good compassionate guy is somebody
that can't survive what she has planned
she can't use him so looks like she's
trying to override him and I'll be
really curious to see how that pans out
I feel bad for teddy would that God I
feel like there's so much more for me to
talk about but right but I don't not
sure what else there is to say besides
just going through the thing point 4.0
the whole thing with Maeve like she's
she's like going full carry at this
point and so she's now she was already
sort of had this command over other
hosts but now she is able to do it just
with her head and I will be really
curious to see to what extent they
explore that and question that because
it's the kind of thing like it again it
makes me wonder are they overpowering
her but then at this point you know I
had the doubts about Shogun world in the
first place so I'm I'm hopeful that
they'll find a way to balance that and
have it work it was a bit of an oh crap
moment though with the Shogun and
realizing he had burned the ears of his
of his closest followers and and the the
right of recognizing oh crap he's
leaking fluid like this
he's not self-aware he's glitching it's
so he's not he's not following programs
but not because he now has freedom of
choices because he's malfunctioning
which makes him even less predictable
yeah this man this is the last episode
I'm I I said it before I'll say it again
I do like Delores this year I certainly
like her more than last season I find
her interesting and I am curious about
what's going on with her but what I am
most curious about by a heavy margin is
the man in black and mave and if you
just want to go back and forth between
the two of them until eventually they
meet up and come head to head because he
you know she remembers that he has
killed her before
so I imagined them having a showdown
eventually yeah yeah that's kind of
where my heart is at this point and
we're still kind of minimizing the the
corporate stuff the corporate espionage
the military response which is good
because that's the least interesting
stuff going on here and I'm fine would
they just keep continuing to peek in
because logistically it does have a part
to play in the narrative but it's
getting no more emphasis than is
necessary for its use in moving the plot
forward and that's good by my estimation
so I'm really liking the way that the
episodes are balanced in terms of where
the emphasis is going who's getting
screen time what elements are getting
screen time how the characters are
panning out the new characters being
introduced this is really really solid
and I had been nervous about a second up
was not a second episode second season
of this show because that first one was
so solid and at all the first one also I
ended in a way that like this could be
the only season and it'll be okay and
you know that that gave me a memory of a
strange of things which also had a first
season that ended in a ways like oh well
that could more or less be the end and
then they gave us a second season and I
was kind of left wondering boy why
couldn't that have been the end but and
so as I've been nervous about this
season of wess world but I am digging
the heck out of this so Westworld season
2 episode 5 have you seen it what did
you think about it mave with the samurai
certain yes yes whatever your thoughts
are drop something down to comment let's
talk about it do all the things like and
subscribe I talked about this show I
talked about other shows there was a new
Doctor Who episode topic video thing
every single Sunday and you can follow
me on Twitter I've got a podcast to do
with my partner called punch like a girl
got a bunch of other stuff links for all
those things are down in the description
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]